And the thing about a comprehensive
narrative is it can't leave out and
archetipal character or it fails.
I can give you an example of this.
Okay.
So how many of you have seen Disney
sleeping beauty?
Okay.
So,
so many of you have.
How many Harvard?
Okay.
So,
so there's a few that happened while the
Disney movies,
you know,
they're kind of standard childhood fairy
in sleeping beauty.
What happens is that the king and queen
give birth to a princess after trying
for a substantial amount of time and you
know,
she arrives healthy and beautiful and
then they have a christening day and
they invite everybody to it,
but they don't invite maleficent who's a
dark,
which roughly speaking,
you know,
like she's,
uh,
she's queen of the underworld that for,
for lack of a better word,
she's the negative element of femininity
and they don't invite her to the party.
And so she shows up anyways and says
that because they didn't invite her,
their daughters going to die when,
when she had 16,
which is roughly the age of,
let's say,
sexual maturation for a story of that
sort.
Now there's another little positive
magic female in the story who mitigates
that death sentence to protracted sleep.
While the idea behind it,
it's a very,
very interesting story.
It's an incredible story in a sense
because what it says is that if your
parents protect you too much from the
dark side of life when you're young,
that what will happen when you start to
on the road to maturity is you'll be so
naive and so fragile that you'll want to
be unconscious instead of paying
attention and that you're going to have
to be rescued from that state by
something and it could be a prince,
which is one which is how that story
plays itself out.
Or it also could be the symbolically
masculine and exploratory element of
your own psyche,
and the stories are ambivalent about
whether it's an external event or an
intern with and it doesn't really
matter.
You know,
the,
the things ended up being the same.
And so that's actually what happens in
this sleeping beauty story.
You know,
at the end,
a prince who's also enslaved by this
terrible negative feminine force,
manages to escape and the maleficent
turns into a dragon and he has to fight
her and then he goes and rescues the
princess and she wakes up and the
kingdoms rejuvenated and everybody's
happy.
It's a classic classic story,
you know,
and it's not.
It's funny because the Disney movie
frozen was put forward as a,
in some sense as a feminist alternative
to the classic fairytales.
And first of all,
you can't do that.
You can't just generate a fairytale.
You know,
there's recent evidence that some of
these fairytales,
the ones that the grimm brothers and the
and Hans Christian Andersen collective
are up to 10,000
years old.
You can't just come up with a counter
fairytale.
That's,
that's just not how it works.
And the way that fairy tale is
structured,
it has nothing to do with,
with the necessity for anyone to rely on
anyone else for anything.
It's a complex portrayal of the denied
dynamic relationship between archetypal
characters.
And you know,
it's one form of the story.
There's lots of different forms of the
story,
but what I liked about sleeping beauty
for example,
and Mrs,
what's Nice about the real fairy tales
is that along with the positive there is
negative and it's real negative.
Like real fairy tales are terrified and
like I don't.
Who is it?
Is it sleeping beauty or in Snow White,
I don't remember.
In one of the famous grimm fairy tales,
one of the evil sisters ends up dancing
and red hot shoes until she dies.
You know,
it's,
they're very,
very violent and and unsettling,
and it's because they,
you know,
they have the quality of genuine folk
tales,
but the reason for that is because
they're dealing with real things like
the Hansel and Gretel story is a good
example of that,
right?
Kids are abandoned out in the woods.
They find something that's too good to
be true inside this thing that's too
good to be true is something that wants
to fatten them up and devour them.
It's a rough story,
but what it's doing at the stories,
the stories have evolved to represent
the fundamental dynamic elements of
existence.
If you conceptualize existence in,
in,
in terms of character,
and the thing is you have to
conceptualize existence in terms of
character if you're a person because
what you do in existence is act out your
character,
so your character is an element of
existence.
Now you might say,
well that doesn't mean that society has
a character,
but actually it does mean that because
partly what happens,
like if you're a socialized,
say into a culture,
the culture exists in the same
relationship to you roughly speaking as
another person does.
So for example,
if you put money in the bank,
which is in principle a representation
of your labor.
What you're doing is entering into a
contract with the broader social world,
which is one of promise essentially
where the future society promises to
return your value at a future date.
So it's a contractual relationship and
the reason that God,
the father is a very common
representation is because treating the
they in in Heideggerian terms,
the others in Heideggerian terms as if
they're an embodied entity actually
works.